[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast livestream I am Brett Weinstein
many of you who have been watching the
Dark Horse podcast know that our live
streams have included Heather huiying
who will not be joining us today
unfortunately she has lost her voice and
rumors are not true this is not from her
participating in the writing she was in
fact Here I am her alibi so we have a
lot going on here this live stream has
been postponed for the SpaceX Dragon
launch that just took place I must say I
had forgotten that it was taking place
because we had rioting here in Portland
last night
Zach and I went down to see the damage
ourselves this morning and by the time I
got back it had slipped my mind that
they were going to launch but in
catching up on that launch I was
reminded that this moment in history has
many odd echoes to approximately the
year of Heather and my birth we were
both born in 1969 that is of course the
year that men first landed on the moon
it is also the year of the Summer of
Love and the juxtaposition
I think suggests a great many things
that are worth investigating
there was a tremendous amount of unrest
at that time surrounding the Vietnam War
among other things there was obviously a
great deal of racial tension there was
hopefulness that arose out of the
ability of human beings to get to the
moon and back safely and I also realized
moments before going on the air that
1968 was the year of the Hong Kong flu a
serious flu pandemic so there were many
echoes of our current situation back
then and I will say on the one hand
that's hopeful because we got through
that on the other hand I think this time
we might be in quite a bit deeper there
are things that haunt our landscape that
did not
exist in 1968 and 1969 we were not all
in the sway of algorithms that we cannot
check and that have unknown influence
over our thinking and the way that we
interact and I am quite concerned that
even given similar ingredients that we
are in a great deal more danger this
time around our election looming also
adds a a certain amount of pressure to
the mix that could end very badly so I
had several things I wanted to discuss
today to be honest they interact in so
many different ways that I'm not exactly
sure where to begin
obviously the riots that have followed
the death of George Floyd which happened
very dramatically on videotape which
presumably everyone has seen those riots
now having spread across the country
including here to Portland are a major
phenomenon what kind of phenomenon they
are is I think up for debate and in some
sense the feeling I am getting having
seen the damage today and seeing what
has come across my Twitter feed tells me
that they may actually be several
different phenomena interacting I don't
think they're going to interact in a
positive way and I'm hoping that we by
thinking carefully about what we are
seeing can disentangle the threads in
time to save ourselves from a noisy
nightmare alright so let us talk about
what has taken place
George Floyd has been apparently killed
on videotape by a white police officer
George Floyd of course was black he was
killed by a white police officer who
kneeled on his neck for more than eight
minutes says he said he couldn't breathe
and then apparently stopped breathing
that on the one hand seems to be a very
simple story I think it is transparent
to anybody who looked at the video that
something very wrong
in that moment on the other hand it is
very difficult to know what it is that
occurred and one of the concerns that I
have is that these protests which have
now morphed into riots are effectively
predicated on the fact that we know what
the story was and if it turns out that
we don't know exactly what the story was
and there are lots of ways that that
could be true
then we have been moved far down a road
under some kind of false pretenses now
again I'm not saying that this is the
case it could be that that video is
exactly what it appears to be that this
is a cop who had a race problem and that
that race problem resulted in his
complete indifference to the fact that
he was suffocating a man to death who
died in front of many witnesses and
other cops and the other cops did
nothing but we also live in America and
in America this cop is do a fair trial
in fact if his punishment is to mean
anything it has to follow a fair trial
and the the way that this has unfolded
does raise a question about how any fair
trial could possibly happen because at
some level the violence that has
unfolded already will be reinvigorated
if any result other than a full
conviction on the maximum charges occurs
but and in fact the protesters have
demanded that the charges that have been
leveled which as I understand it are
third-degree murder and manslaughter are
not sufficient on the other hand in
order to convict him of something like
first-degree murder you would have to
show something like intent and as
terrible as what is on those videos is
the definition of intent as the law sees
it is narrowly defined and did he intend
to kill George Floyd hard to imagine
that he did on camera so we are headed
for a very tense situation as he is
tried and either convicted of a crime
many do not
regard as sufficient for what they saw
on that tape or he is exonerated for
some reason that we don't yet know now
it could be that the exoneration is a
miscarriage of justice
I believe we saw that in the Rodney King
case many years ago many of you will be
too young to remember that but it was
quite a parallel situation where Rodney
King who I believe had tried to evade
police when he was finally stopped was
beaten on videotape and at the time
video cameras were sufficiently rare
that the world was shocked by by what it
saw as I recall the the argument was
levelled that he that the officers could
not get a fair trial in the jurisdiction
where this had taken place the trial was
moved I think to Simi Valley and Simi
Valley was a place where they found a
sympathetic jury and despite the fact
that these cops had seemed seemingly
needlessly brutalized Rodney King
they were exonerated and that resulted
in riots so we've seen this pattern
before we are now in a highly charged
situation where a system whose greatest
strength is that it does demand that you
be proven guilty beyond a reasonable
doubt in a court of law in front of a
jury of your peers that that that very
important accomplishment that is handed
to us in the Constitution is now very
difficult to deploy in the context of of
George Floyd and and George Floyd's
death and this officer all right so
I just want to point out a couple of
ways in which this could become
difficult to manage in a in a court
setting what if this officer is just a
terrible person but that this wasn't
racially motivated and he you know has a
history of brutalizing people okay maybe
that plays into it and maybe it doesn't
what if as there is some indication I
believe in the medical examiner's report
what if George Floyd was having trouble
breathing before he ever hit the ground
and what the officer did certainly made
things worse but was not the cause of
his death for example what if he had had
a heart attack
ended up on the ground the officer put
his knee on the the neck of George Floyd
and George Floyd died I think needlessly
because certainly the officers should
have gotten him help at that point but
nonetheless these are the kinds of
things that could complicate a trial
okay now let's move on for a second from
the question of whether or not a fair
trial is conceivable in this case for
that officer and as much as I saw a
brutal officer on that tape who I
believe was engaged in a very serious
crime which demands very serious
punishment I know that a trial is
necessary in order to figure out the
facts of of the scenario okay we now
face spreading unrest and violence and
as I said Zack and I went down to
downtown Portland and looked at some of
the damage firsthand and I think
probably it makes sense to show you some
of what we saw so let's see Zack how do
we do this I can't yeah but why don't
you just start and go and go through
stuff all right so here you see a
picture of ACAB spray-painted over the
sign at the corner on the Ninth Circuit
building in downtown Portland
the Ninth Circuit being a Federal Court
of Appeals so I must say looking at this
spray-paint here all cops are bastards
that's what a CA B means I find it a
preposterous phrase certainly some cops
are bastards I've run into them but all
cops being bastards seems incredibly
improbable
and the claim itself seems deliberately
designed to inflame cops to bring out
the worst in them in order to reinforce
the belief that there is no Humanity in
them I know that this sentiment was
deployed at Evergreen and that it wasn't
true there after the Evergreen riots
broke out I got to know Stacy Brown the
Chief of Police there who I found
completely humane and rational and
decent to the core
so all cops are bastards can't possibly
be right and here it's being
spray-painted on a federal court of
appeals and I had the question to the
people who did this spray-painting do
they have any idea what the court of
appeals represents do they have any idea
what role it plays in protecting them
from tyranny I have the sense that they
they surely do not and yet and yet here
it is all right let's move on one all
right here's a car that had been burned
out of course there is no indication
about whether there was some sort of a
gripe against the owner of this car but
I have to say that the violence and
damage that we saw in evidence
downtown suggested not an entirely
random pattern as you'll see but a
highly random pattern so this will just
have been a car that was parked in the
wrong place at the wrong time and burned
out for I don't know to demonstrate
someone's power or something like that
all right move on one okay here we have
the Apple Store this is just right
adjacent to the circuit to the Ninth
Circuit Court there
and spray-painted here is cops hate us
now I don't know who us is in this bit
of graffiti I don't know whether that
was intended to mean the anarchists who
I believe if did most of the damage here
or if it's supposed to mean something
else
but I will say as you will see an other
graffiti that is documented in these
pictures the cops have been thoroughly
provoked
now is there a long history of bad
policing in America is there a reason
for for suspicion that bad policing may
have something to do with episodes like
the one that took place with George
Floyd or habitual bad policing sure
there is but to turn the cops into a
monolithic phenomenon and to declare
their hatred for us is so childish and
so dangerous that it is hard to imagine
that the people who did it could mistake
it for the solution to any problem okay
move on all right here we have the Apple
Store and the Apple Store looks like
Apple stores in many cities its glass
all the way around and almost all of the
panes had clearly been attacked with
heavy objects now this will begin to
show the pattern the attacks to the
extent that they were not random and
there were certainly some that looked
random included a great many attacks on
stores that sell high priced items and
there were occasionally bits of graffiti
I think meant to rationalize this
complaining about slave labor that goes
into the production of these Apple
products for example on the other hand
the impression that we were certainly
left with looking at this was that at
some level the breakdown in order was
being used as an excuse to loot high
quality
the stores that sell high quality goods
in other words somehow these anarchists
in their day life are regular citizens
who covet things whether or not they
should and then at the point that they
have an excuse like the death of George
Floyd they go after the stores that have
the things that they might otherwise
wish to purchase I don't know what was
taken or not taken from the Apple store
most of the windows look like they held
I guess they would have to be high
quality windows to not be routinely
broken by petty criminals but but anyway
it was quite dramatic and the pattern
was quite evident all right move on all
right now this photo is one of two I
don't know if they're in sequence here
or not this photo is of a trash can near
one of the important parks in downtown
Portland and the trash can has been
burned and looking at this and the other
picture which will come up here at some
point yeah if you know where it is okay
here's the other one this is a trash can
with a sign that somebody has made out
of cardboard and put on it and they've
taken the trash out of it and they've
strewn it all around in the same Park
there is a porta potti that has been
destroyed and a shrine for George Floyd
but in any case the attack on the trash
cans I think it's particularly telling
because everybody benefits from the
proper functioning of municipal trash
cans and trash collection service that
picks these things up just the same way
everybody benefits from a city in which
you can walk down almost any street and
not worry about random violence or theft
you know the policing and the trash when
they work correctly are nearly invisible
and they make life vastly better for us
and it has struck me since I began
encountering anarchists years ago
actually during the Aki
by protests we're anarchists took over
the movement that the anarchists have no
concept of what actually makes their
lives possible they have a fairy tale
notion about what things are unnecessary
and what things they could do better
themselves and attacking trash cans and
dragging the trash out into the street
is exactly the kind of confusion that I
see at Evergreen the anarchists famously
wanted to eliminate the police from
campus and they wanted what they called
community patrols and inside of hours of
starting their community patrols after
Jorge bridges stood the police down
people were being intimidated and
brutalized by bat wielding students
that's what community patrols broke down
into the lack of a system like the
courts the lack of policing that is
properly set in motion these things have
almost immediate consequences on
civilization that the people who see
only the problems with them do not
anticipate so did the people who took
the trash out of this trashcan or burned
the one across the street or crushed the
Porta Potty thereby depriving people
including homeless people of some place
to use the toilet do they think that
they have improved the city I can't
imagine that they do and yet they behave
with this kind of arrogance all right
move on here another instance that shows
the pattern what store there was no
other store on this block that had been
attacked what store was attacked the
Sprint store why the Sprint store
presumably because it had phones and all
of these anarchists are also users of
cell phones that might desire a little
upgrade so this is really tarnishing any
legitimate complaint they might have go
on all right
now here again you can see one of the
problems with the the protests that have
become riots this is a picture of some
graffiti and it was really all over
downtown and it says rest in power big
Floyd and then you see the anarchist a
now I don't know of any evidence that
says the George Floyd had any sympathies
with anarchists I find it hard to
imagine and the attempt to graft
anarchism on to his death in order to
justify some movement that as anybody
who lives in Portland knows is sort of
constantly bubbling under the surface
looking for a fight right suddenly they
have something that they can claim is
motivating them and it is really just a
rationalization as far as I can tell all
right ok I can't breathe that as a quote
from George Floyd and this says [ __ ]
pigs oink oink right again a deliberate
provocation of the cops now there were
police all over downtown today and I
took the opportunity to go talk to a set
I just saw some standing on the corner
and Zack and I went up to him asked him
if they had any thoughts and they were
initially very reluctant to say anything
and you know I appealed to their being
citizens of Portland and we being
citizens of Portland and I just wanted
to hear what they have to say and one
cop said well you know this is troubling
because he said I speaking of himself I
have nothing in common with the cop who
did this to George Floyd he says the
only things I have in common with them
are that I'm white and I'm a cop and I
don't understand why it is that this
attack on all police has to happen in
response to this event he says I was
sickened to by what I saw
so that is completely inconsistent of
course with the all cops are bastards
belief system but the all cops are
bastards belief system is really just a
simplifying assumption that allows those
who are engaged in it not to have to
worry too much about who's on the other
other side of their violence okay go on
okay here we've got a video I'm gonna be
quiet so you can hear this is actually
this is the building Heather and I have
worked in this is the bank on the bottom
floor the Chase Bank and these guys are
replacing all the windows in this one
we're broke
it does watch what happens here at the
very end
now I
I can't hear this you guys can hear the
audio here but look that guy said as he
walked by was proudly that he had
participated he said he had helped to
tear apart the bank there now I don't
have any great love of chase chases one
of the banks that we use and I have my
problems with them nonetheless here's a
guy walking around in broad daylight
proud to have destroyed this institution
now what does he think is going to
happen to the costs that they inflicted
on Chase that's going to come back to
chase customers and just like everything
else it will be dealt with did they
really think they solved a problem I
can't imagine how they would and yet
they certainly seem to okay so oh yes
actually we should we should look at
that tweak now this is mayor Ted wheeler
Ted Wheeler says burning buildings with
people inside stealing from small and
large businesses threatening and
harassing reporters all in the middle of
the pandemic where people have already
lost everything
this isn't calling for meaningful change
in our communities this is disgusting
this is actually a highly unusual tweet
for for our mayor I have been highly
critical of our mayor among other things
for coddling the so called anti-fascists
who are constantly picking fights in the
streets of Portland by coddling them by
effectively letting them do what they do
without arresting them even when they're
doing absurd things like taking over
intersections and directing traffic he
has left them with the impression that
what they are doing is okay but even Ted
wheeler has now apparently had enough
now I had some frankly pretty pointed
things to say about mayor wheeler and I
noticed that the tweet below this one
says that he has actually been called
back to the city that he had left to go
attend to his dying mother
and in light of the fact that he is
facing that terrible crisis I'm inclined
to give him a pass I do however want to
point out that if Ted wheeler has
finally understood that the coddling of
the so-called
the fascist is only going to result in
more violence that's a very good thing
for Portland
I hope the lesson sticks and mayor
wheeler I I'm sorry to hear about your
mom that's a it's a terrible thing to
face and I think all decent people
understand that no matter whether we're
supporters of yours or not that you're
going through something serious yes
alright so now we have we have some
other video business here but I'll want
to take mayor wheelers tweet down okay
so what I want to connect this to is the
really we have two movements in motion
at the same time and they are
interacting in some kind of what I would
say is a dangerous way now in the past
I've said some things about black lives
matter black lives matter is a movement
that I would like to be able to support
because I support the concept black
lives are undervalued I believe any
decent person who evaluated the evidence
would recognize that black lives are
undervalued in the US and that results
in many things including violence
sometimes by police on the other hand
the black lives matter movement is not
simply about that point it's about many
other points some of which I can't
support and so the the compromised
nature of black lives matter means that
I have to stay at arm's length from it
even if I don't feel naturally that
that's where I should be the that's so
that's one tension inside the the black
lives matter movement but then we have a
second tension and the second tension
has to do with the anarchists the
so-called anti-fascists who are
basically utilizing the unrest that is
that exists as a result of this video of
George Floyd's death for their own
purposes and the point here is that they
are in fact jeopardizing the very thing
they claim to be attempting to advance
they are
aiming to be very upset about what
happened to George Floyd but at the same
time they are engaged in random violence
and looting and those two things
undercut the claim that this is a
movement that is motivated by
frustration at a broken system so you
want to show the first of those videos
act yeah that's the reality of what we
did and we're right now all right
like I said to all my white brothers and
sisters we appreciate y'all being out
here and supporting us hey this is not
y'all space my ass is not jokes pants
period we don't need this [ __ ] right
here because what our reality is when
this [ __ ] is all said and done when we
wake up we still gonna be black in
America you know that's not nothing
against none of y'all that's not what
this is that's not what I'm saying but
we're not going to allow y'all to go up
there and start causing chaos and
confusion it's just not gonna happen
okay so I wasn't able to hear the video
with you but a memory serves you had a
black guy respectfully but pointedly
telling white folks who were engaged in
violent and destructive rioting that
they were doing the black community no
favors that at the end of the day the
black people have to go back to being
black at the white people get to go home
to do something else and so the fusion
between these two movements is
understood inside at least many parts of
the the the race the race based part of
the movement understood to be dangerous
and destructive can we show the other
video
engaged in violence black woman just
pleading with them to stop yes partly
because I've seen the same dynamic
unfold up close those of you who
listened in to our last livestream about
the Evergreen meltdown and how that went
for Heather and for me we'll remember
the discussion of of Odette who was our
good friend and our student who was
challenged by by rioters at Evergreen as
some kind of a traitor for studying
science and for not seeing things the
way they did in any case these tensions
are important and those of us who are
outside of these protests and riots need
to remember that we're not looking at
one thing we're looking at several
things and that these things are being
distorted by the lens through which we
are looking at them I guess I would also
point to the very interesting fact of
the two places CNN shows up prominently
in this story one of them a CNN reporter
arrested while reporting from a place
that he had been told to stand by police
on camera quite dramatic that was in
Minneapolis in Atlanta the CNN
headquarters were of course attacked by
protesters which is nothing if not
ironic because CNN has bent over
backwards to coddle this perspective as
foolish as it is so the and I'm not
saying that the whole perspective is
foolish but CNN has bent over backwards
to coddle all of these perspectives that
have been fused together into something
incoherent and what what was the upshot
or what was the outgrowth of they're
spending all of that time trying to find
reason we're in many cases there wasn't
any is they got targeted because
doesn't doesn't pay any attention to who
has done its bidding frankly it just
comes for everybody alright so this
leads me to the following the following
point we're in very serious trouble
America has a very serious race problem
we have not fully dealt with it we have
done a lot but as with many or actually
all complex problems this is a
diminishing returns issue where the easy
stuff has all been done and what we are
left with are all the difficult things
the things that are hard to spot that
are a bit subtle that require us to
think outside the box in order to
discover what solution might actually
function and because of that I believe
there is natural frustration and that
natural frustration is pent up and I
believe that people in especially the
black community have reason to be
impatient and they have reason to notice
that year after year patterns that
systemic systemically
shut them out of opportunity remain and
what they get is a lot of lip service
from especially the Democratic Party so
what I want to do is I want to talk
about how it is that we are going to get
out of this predicament without
descending into at the very least
madness and I believe we are already
effectively on a slippery slope to
madness in light of the Cova 19 pandemic
in light of the election year that we
are in it seems likely that what will
happen is more heat and more pressure
will be added to the situation and that
is going to result in an increased
likelihood of it boiling over in some
even more spectacular and dangerous way
so as a patriotic American I want to
find a way out of that predicament what
I would like to do
is proposed something that might allow
us to well not to put too fine a point
on it to rescue the Republic from a
trajectory that seems certain to tear it
apart but first we have to talk about
what the predicament really is so we
have a president who engages in behavior
that is nothing if not stunning a couple
days ago he tweeted and he quoted
essentially a threat of shooting
basically the quote was something to the
effect of when the looting starts the
shooting starts and this is apparently a
quote from the 60s 1968 I believe that
could not help but be a dog whistle to
certain parts of his base Twitter rather
absurdly decided to label the tweet as
troubling but needing to stay up in
order for you know for the greater good
or something like that
now the fact is the man is the President
of the United States irrespective of
what he says no matter how vile no
matter how dangerous we need access to
it we need access to it if for no other
reason than to know how dangerous it is
so the idea that Twitter is debating
whether or not to protect us from
something the president said is absurd
on its face Twitter should step out of
the way they should treat us as adults
and they should allow us to see what is
being said we can then discuss what its
meaning is but whether we get to hear
what was said of course we do any other
choice makes no sense whatsoever okay so
I want to present a model and a
principle that are the basis for what I
see as a plan that could get us out of
our predicament so the model is this for
almost my entire life I was born in 1969
for almost my entire
life the two-party system has functioned
like a influence-peddling racket and
there are two parties in that
influence-peddling racket you have the
Democratic Party and you have the
Republican Party both of whom have their
version of it now I think the Democratic
Party's version went from a kind of
light influence peddling to absolutely
all-encompassing influence peddling at
about the time that Bill Clinton was
elected the first time Bill Clinton's
first administration marked the point at
which the Democratic Party abandoned
working people and decided instead to
peddle its influence to wealthy
interests that did not have the public
interests at heart so that created a
structure in which these two teams
effectively battled for a larger
fraction of the influence-peddling pie
but basically the whole system
functioned to exclude the interests of
common people we were shut out we were
constantly being sold out by one or the
other party and each party paid lip
service to to the two working people but
you know inexplicably policy never
worked substantially in our favor
so what happened in 2016 was effectively
Trump staged an insurgency that
insurgency was too many people hopeful
because it did represent a challenge to
the influence peddlers who had treated
public policy as their own private bank
account and this is quite understandable
you can imagine living in a town in
which rival crime families exist if some
new syndicate showed up and challenged
them you would at first be relieved to
see some
fighting back against the people that
had you under their thumb but in Trump's
case he effectively functions as a third
crime family and at this point the red
crime family has made an uneasy peace
with him so they've now joined their
interest that doesn't mean that they
were permanently joined but for the
moment they have joined together and the
blue crime family is very interested in
restoring the order that used to exist
it wants nothing more than to eliminate
Trump and many people have understood
eliminating Trump to be the solution to
some problem but of course it isn't the
solution to some problem if it returns
us to a state in which the red crime
family and the blue crime family
continue to peddle influence and sell us
out that system is what created the
vulnerability that we currently have it
actually created the frustration that is
currently manifesting itself in the form
of riots across the country so what I
want to propose is that we start by
looking at fellow Americans people we
don't necessarily understand because
they are choosing to vote in some way
that we find unconscionable and my point
to to you is that it is unacceptable to
hold people responsible for making bad
choices when they only had bad choices
to choose from if the menu contains only
bad choices people will choose among
them and holding them responsible for
having made a bad choice makes no sense
now some people will quibble some
choices are worse than others and that's
true but effectively we are prevented
from seeing the predicament we are in by
a battle over which choice is worse it's
like this election after election the
lesser of two evils paradigm has ruled
our electoral cycles for a reason and it
is because it distracts us from the
glaring fact that our system keeps
handing us only bad choices and it's not
because they're only bad
choices to be found but it's because
anything that was not a bad choice would
threaten the influence-peddling racket
of the major parties so of course those
things are dead on arrival and this is
what we've seen again this year there
were interesting candidates in the
Democratic field all of them eliminated
by the end and now what we are left with
apparently is a competition between
these two decrepit clowns now I don't
know about you but I cannot imagine a
worse moment to be left with a choice
between decrepit clowns than this one in
light of kovat 19 in light of the racial
tensions that are threatening to tear
the country apart in light of the
predicament we find ourselves in with
China which manufactures most of what it
is that we consume and yet is a hostile
state with hostile interests that is
clearly aware of the vulnerability we
have created for ourselves so what are
we to do that's really the question I
want to propose a way out of this mess
and I will just tell you at the get-go
anything that someone proposes to escape
the hegemony of the duopoly to escape
the the election as we see it shaping up
is going to sound far-fetched but I
would ask you if the answer is this
seems far-fetched so I'm just going to
choose from the menu that I've been
given then where are we going to be
after the election where will we be four
years from now will there be an
opportunity then or will it just be
another absurd set of choices okay so
deep breath
here's the proposal the proposal is that
we draft two people now these people
have to have certain characteristics
they need to be Patriots they need to be
courageous they need to be highly
capable now if we can find two such
people
it would be ideal if they came from
different sides of the usual political
divide that is to say it would be great
to have somebody from the center-right
and somebody from the center-left we
would draft them and they would agree to
rule as a team actually govern as a team
is a better choice of words so they
would agree to govern as a team and the
choice of who would run at the top of
the ticket would be made arbitrarily
they'd flip a coin and we'd see who was
going to run in the top spot and who was
going to be vice-president but with the
acknowledgement that in all matters they
would attempt to rule to govern by
consensus and that only in circumstances
where they could not reach agreement or
where a decision had to be made quickly
like in some sort of a military
confrontation would the person at the
top of the ticket have the final say so
this team then after four years would
reverse roles whoever had run at the top
of the ticket in the first election
would run for the vice presidential spot
and the former vice president would run
for the presidential spot and this would
continue until either some other ticket
was voted into office or one of the
parties had been in the presidential
role twice and therefore had become
ineligible as a vice presidential
candidate at which point they would be
replaced by somebody else who was
suitable now this plan solves a number
of different problems most importantly
it escapes the hegemony of the parties
it would put highly competent Patriots
in the position of ruling or governing
in the American people's interest in a
in a transparent way it does not require
us to alter anything about the
Constitution or to pass any laws in
order to make it work now of course it
has obstacles primary among them is the
question of who the individuals were
chosen would be now I've done a lot of
thinking about that question and I've
concluded that the person who is best
suited for the role on the center-right
is fairly clear and I would suggest that
it would be Admiral William McRaven hey
folks apparently I am once again live I
think you will all agree the timing of
that failure was uncanny I'm gonna try
not to think too hard about the meaning
of why our system suddenly collapsed at
that moment and just simply pick up
where I was that has asked me to convey
that because we have been forced to
resort to a backup system we know that
the sound is not quite as high-quality
as we would like we are recording
locally and we may be able to do
something about the quality afterwards
most important from my perspective
though is that we pick up the thread we
were on and continue forward so that you
guys have the full idea I believe the
last thing you heard me say was that in
the center-right position I would
advocate Admiral William McRaven current
Chancellor of the University of Texas he
is obviously a courageous person he is
obviously highly competent and clearly a
patriot
so I do not believe there is any strong
reason that we would need to find some
different candidate where he willing on
the left it's a little bit more
difficult there are some people I really
like for that spot in each case there is
something that makes them just shy of
perfect in the end I have concluded that
the best person for the role is probably
Andrew yang in Andrew Yang's case he has
demonstrated that he is capable of
thinking outside the box he's
demonstrated that he's courageous and
all-in when it comes to mounting a
campaign and I'm sure he would do the
same thing in the role in the role that
I've proposed the downsides as I see it
with Andrew are that in the aftermath of
his being in my opinion pushed out of
the Democratic race he embraced Biden
and he went over to CNN who had treated
him so badly during the primary that
said I don't see either of those as
fatal problems and I would certainly
trust him to do an excellent job were he
elected okay so now you have the
outlines of the plan what problems does
it solve well in one fell swoop it would
remove the power of the parties over the
presidency and it would put the
presidency in the hands of people with
excellent leadership capacity excellent
insight and most importantly people who
hold the public interest in high regard
all right so that's the plan now I think
probably the best thing to do is for me
to take a brief break and then to return
and we can do our question-and-answer
session I will start with the questions
that came in on the initial stream and I
believe we have now switched to the
second stream and your Oh Zack tells me
we're still in the first stream all
right
well this uncanny collapse of our system
in mid discussion has left me a little
bit confused about where we are
technologically but nonetheless I think
it makes sense at this point for me to
take a five minute break and then return
sorry folks so that is telling me that
we need 15 minutes in order to make this
work so I will take 15 minutes and I
will return to answer super chat
questions all right signing off for now
you